the audience is not dying out I think
the audience is very hard to replace
because has always been older this has
always been an older person's
entertainment as far as concert going is
concerned and so what we need to do is
find a way to capture the interest of
people in their late 20s and their 30s
early 40s who's never been at a
classical music concert or once when
they were children so you have to
reintroduce them it's you know similar
to reintroducing a child to vegetables
they hated when they were children so
we're not dealing with a group of people
who learn to play an instrument all
through childhood the way I did or my
grandparents and parents generation and
then decide become professionals so it
take baseball right people who do a lot
of amateur baseball playing love the
professional game people who skied love
to watch skiing people who golf are
worried about Tiger Woods no sane person
would watch a televised golf game would
you no I wouldn't watch a golf game
unless I played because when I play golf
which I don't I would probably
understand why Tiger which is good for
me Tiger Woods is some kind of you know
conspiracy you know famous guy hitting
small ball long distances I don't
understand it makes no sense to me it
has no particular value so I'll never
watch golf I'll turn the channel away
from the golf game so the audience has
always traditionally been built on
amateurs who are fascinated tennis is
the best example there are a lot of
tennis clubs out there people hitting
the ball and they when they see a real
good tennis player they know what that
person does now we don't have that
audience anymore in classical music by
and large so we have to find a way to
connect music to their lives the way
museums have done with painting the
people who watch you know are chose or
go to museums aren't amateur painters
they've never tried to pay but they
understand it the people who read books
and literature haven't tried their hands
writing novels or poetry but they love
to read how do
do that with music to a population where
it's new to their adulthood
that's task number one and I think we
can do that as they were changing the
concert format changing what we play and
how we play it in terms of the context
of of performance the other object about
classical music which is a great thing
is that it is an international rage
there are more young people out there
learning to play instruments than ever
before and they play better than ever
before the level of play is much higher
than it ever was and the number of
people selling violin and piano and
Western classical music in China Korea
Japan Vietnam India Venezuela all over
the world is fantastic it's a growing
business in terms of the people learning
to play it young people as children and
if adolescents and young adults learning
to play the instruments very well so we
have a very vital growing group of
instrumentalists we have a lot of people
writing music for the concert stage
trouble is actually convincing the
audience now they're not enough young
players who are not going to become
musicians to make up the audience
because they're starting the instrument
at too high a level in other words there
are too many people in the minor league
so to speak or going through the college
pipeline and they're not enough slots in
the NFL that's more or less the idea so
the question is can you get a lot of
people who've never played football to
watch the game are people who are going
to be really enjoyable think it's an
enjoyable time to sit and listen to a
concert and that's our task which is
capture the interest of the adult young
adult and the one of the places to start
actually is in college one of the real
failures in my view is the failure of
music departments in universities to
make music appreciation really enjoyable
to college students and they've gone
into the very arcane fields of
musicology and they've sort of made a
profession out of their expertise so we
need to rescue classical music from its
own defenders